it's been two years it's time for me to
google myself
see what's new what's up what has
changed nothing probably let's check it
out
and as always the first thing that shows
up
pewdiepie net worth pewdiepie keyboard
oh let me tell you all about this
keyboard
guys check out ghost keyboard pewdiepie
edition
it's the best keyboard on the planet
thank you look
i can type over here i can type over
here
it's not even on screen and i can be
typing right now
if you want a game like this you can
changing the game with the pewdiepie
keyboard
we got more additions coming to this too
as well so uh
now it's a great time to be a gamer
check it out link in description what's
that we also have gamer mouse
that's right the best looking mouse in
the game
i love this okay it's very light and as
you know
the lighter a mouse is the better any
more quality
it actually makes sense right you want
to start a keyboard and you want to like
i'm not even sure why i'm meaning it uh
i love it
it's cool looking it's so light because
i thought it was so dumb with the holes
but it actually feels kind of
comfortable
it does make it lighter so having a
really nice light mouse feels really
good
i like it it's two products that i'm
generally proud of i think they're
really cool and
if you're interested you can check them
out as well shake on it
[Music]
cool link in description thanks for
supporting the channel
let's get on with the video people are
looking for coco
[ __ ] phone case oh let me tell you guys
new rhino [ __ ] all right whatever net
why don't we start from the top
to the bottom uh as of 2021 pewdiepie's
net worth is estimated to be 40 million
um come on
come on come on come on i'm not going to
say
obviously i'm not going to talk about
money and how much money i make
but 40 million come on
it's pretty a billionaire is he
how the [ __ ] would that happen how much
money what do you think ad revenue is
doing to me
i'm an actor apparently well how much is
felix shelberg's net worth
come on hey i got more than the wayne
hey i got more than nadja komenasi
hey i got more than yelena oh no oh oh
oh what the [ __ ] are all these rich
people goddamn
i feel like money is such a redundant
thing where it's like you only have to
experience it
yourself to realize how little it does
for your well-being
or or your happiness i should say rather
but there's no point in me saying it
it's not like oh okay maybe i don't want
the limeball then thank you felix
you've changed my perspective wasn't it
jim carrey that said it
i think everyone should get rich and
famous and do everything they ever
dreamed of so they can see that it's not
the answer
that's a bit of an annoying way to put
it but i just think we put too much
weight on it
that's it it's great it can be useful
but i think
in general we we tend to romanticize
this concept of fame and money
which is fun too hey that's why the
lottery exists
it's like a ticket to go you know what
if i win [ __ ] this guy
and then this guy it gives you a chance
to dream in a weird way
i've been really blessed in my career
but i didn't start this to earn a lot of
money and
that's not why i'm doing it now so i
don't know what to tell you guys
i think one of them was the most fun
thing to do is to do
work on yourself right uh learn a new
skill
practice certain things every single day
to me that's what brings uh
fulfillment there you go preachy
pewdiepie i'll stop i'm sorry
pewdiepie height dude i am not 175.
what the [ __ ] is this
oh no we're gonna bring in the height
controversies now
why did they come to this oh there's a
whole website that obsessed about
people's heights is [ __ ] weird
look at him he's 2-9 max
yeah yeah look i'm hunching over for
joji i'm clearly 180 plus
let's go fddf you got it you got it
right confirmed
confirmed y'all can talk about it now in
your little forum you [ __ ] nerds
pewdiepie age well that shouldn't be
hard there you go can't dispute that one
i'm too old for this [ __ ] oh yeah
they have this like parents review right
oh no
i got a terrible rating parents say age
12 plus
kids say 11 age plus he's a great role
model and has
reliable news i can trust his news
few news the most respected news source
on
youtube yeah i'd say 15 plus probably
feels fair i wouldn't want anyone
younger
he's an amazing role model written by an
adult hey
thanks adults awesome likable sweet has
changed over the years
this is so i didn't expect nice ones i'm
over 40 years old let's go not as bad as
you might think peterborough can be very
controversial but he's not as bad as you
think
he's not a nazi or racist thank you i'm
glad we settled that we squashed that
once and for all
who would have thought don't watch my
own videos i swear like a [ __ ] sailor
see once you get on a roll
you [ __ ] all the [ __ ]
what is my sub count oh yeah they can't
track it anymore
it says 109 come on guys every sub i get
a sub what is my actual socket
yeah we can watch it real time here i
didn't realize they did this
why is it not moving come on
come on refresh it says updating live
really is this stagnant subscribe god
damn it
hey let's go
[Laughter]
i remember when i used to have
notifications on my videos
and i would get after uploading one
video i saw i got two subs
not even two and then i got three and i
was like [ __ ]
yeah oh i went down too god damn it
stop it stop i was like dude um that was
um that video was such a good video
damn that was a good video how things
change huh
it's so crazy when something goes beyond
your wildest
wildest dreams like i wanted to get i
never told anyone
right because i thought it was stupid
but i was like dude what if i like could
get the biggest in sweden that would
just be like
what biggest channel in sweden that
would be insane dude
getting like one a million subs that
would no that's not possible
that was just like to me
incomprehensible
here we are i don't know what to do with
it help me
thank you guys now let's get into the
ish pewdiepie or
what if okay is pewdiepie rich uh sure
a millionaire sure swedish absolutely
billionaire
no married yes vegan no why do people
think this
i am a pescetarian you see the souls of
them
well i don't know i watched this
documentary what was it called
see spirits or some [ __ ] i was saying
how bad it was for the environment
fishing and i kind of feel bad so i
don't know anymore
sorca tweeted wait is pewdiepie vegan
now
thanks to sorcia she converted me this
is 2016.
okay i can't believe that showed up
sweetie should be getting minecraft
jesus christ what the [ __ ] is wrong with
my twitter
it's people american well reddit meme
says yes
the richard youtuber i don't think so
who is the richest youtuber
jeffree star apparently what it has to
be one of the beauty brands because
statistically i think if you have a high
female audience
your not just ad revenue but also your
uh
your sales in merch and everything it's
just like 10 times more
it's really girls by all the sh thank
you girls
watching
guys i'm just kidding i really don't
care i'm glad i have a good mix of
girls and and guys watching i'd feel
weird if i only had only guys that were
only girls
should we look at that i'm curious now
here we go
sixteen percent of you are not
subscribed guys
hit the subscribe button uh twenty four
percent female a
[Music]
75 male hey
are 18 to 24 then 25 to 34
and in between these but i assume a lot
of people lie about their h2 i mean i
think my channel is 709 which is the
maximum on youtube so
yo shout out to my indian bros what the
[ __ ]
that's really picked up yeah philippine
bros
yeah canadian bros yeah indonesian
sweden let's go sweden best country in
the world
why is pewdiepie not showing his face
[Laughter]
this is coco
cause they're melon come on old news
so popular well i don't [ __ ] know i
was the least popular kid in my school
so you tell me
i still can't wrap my head around it
honestly thank you guys
as an introvert at least i realized that
i have somewhat of a likable personality
i appreciate that thank you
hey if you're an introvert people like
you don't worry about it it's all right
can pewdiepie speak japanese no i wish
speak swedish yo absolutely
nah speak russian and uh
so we can tell it not draw uh
sure this is kind of fun will pewdiepie
quit youtube who knows he's already quit
he's dead
i can join the dream smp
oh man retire well i said this a couple
months ago i already considered myself
retired
i know i mean like subbing and all that
but i'm not playing the youtube game
like i used to do
i'm just doing it for fun i hate to live
my life always trying to chase
things right that just seems like a sad
existence to me i'd rather just have fun
while i'm doing it
will pewdiepie play minecraft again yes
always best game can't wait for the new
update
i'm so [ __ ] hyped pewdiepie quran
yeah i mentioned in a live stream so i'm
gonna
read the quran i'm like sure at some
point i'm sure i'll read it i'm pretty
sure i'll read most religious texts
creative muslim now
i don't think that's how that works how
much can pewdiepie
bench let's go let's go
dude i am weak still i'm trying i'm
getting there
how much computed by deadlift bro i
could probably
a max do 170
yeah probably how pewdiepie saved
minecraft
people attribute way too much to me i
don't think i have anything to do with
it the game was already
resurging i just hopped on the trend
come on
how pewdiepie started sussexlive.com.uk
nice let's see what the news are saying
i'm pewdiepie's addicted to minecraft
thank you
no controversies let's go the indian
express
what's my diet no his diet what is my
diet
they don't say amazing oh wait
oh i eat more protein amazing what a
diet
all right well that's me googling myself
every subscriber i get more subscriber
guys
i want my subs to go up up up up up
thank you for supporting me throughout
the year it's really fun i'm still
having fun with a [ __ ] so
thank you boys and girls thank you
thank you hey hit it
hit it smash it